[Music]
well um
thank you everyone it's a pleasure to be
here and an honor to be with rupert whom
i've read for over 20 years it's very
strange to be on stage with him now
i'm a research fellow in associate
lecture at exeter university where i'm
doing research on philosophy and
psychedelics
and rupert of course has
a background in philosophy and
researching psychedelics and of course
rupert is a well and needs no
introductions well-known biologist on
the controversial side let's say
so rupert and i have been in
correspondence for a week or so
in
to prepare for this event and and one of
the we exchanged a few texts
and uh one of the texts i received from
rupert is his recent article is the sun
conscious and i'm very interested in
this because i did my phd on pan
psychism the view that minds are
ubiquitous throughout nature
and um
so i i was going to start by asking you
um
if you might explain that article a
little bit why it seems preposterous to
some people to think that the sun might
be conscious and how that sort of
philosophy
might relate to psychedelic experience
well in traditional cultures it's taken
for granted that the sun is conscious
it's a god or a goddess in japan it's a
goddess
in germanic
um
you know in in latin cultures it's a god
in india it's syria
um
so it's taken for granted that the sun
the stars and the heavenly bodies are
conscious beings that's why we call the
planets by the names of gods and
goddesses
um
but
in and in the middle ages um
philosophers like saint thomas aquinas
thought of the
planets and the stars as
conscious beings uh with angelic
intelligences and plato called the uh
planets the visible gods
um so the idea that the heavens are
animate that they're
alive and conscious is a very old idea
and i would say pretty well universal
what makes our own culture so eccentric
is that in the 17th century at the
beginning of the scientific revolution
the whole of the heavens and the earth
were declared unconscious inanimate
devoid of life um everything was
mechanical and machine-like
and so in that context asking if the
sun's conscious seems absurd for a
materialist um it's just a stupid
question it's something that you know
primitive people might think ignorant
people might think children might think
because they draw the sun with a smiley
face
so they may think it's conscious but
grown-up mature sensible educated people
ought not even to consider that question
dismiss it with the contempt it deserves
and that's the way it's been treated for
several centuries
um
well i think in my own case
i'm predisposed towards pan psychism in
1990 i wrote a book called the rebirth
of nature about
the reanimation of the world
i lived for seven years in india where
the gayatri mantra is one of the most
fundamental
prayers in hinduism
asking for the blessings of the son to
illuminate our meditation
so what i was doing in this
article in the journal of consciousness
studies is trying to put this idea of
the sun being conscious in the context
of western science and philosophy
and the move towards pan psychism
in philosophy has been a big help
galen strawson helped to open the
floodgates and you're part of this
movement too as a pan cyclist
philosopher
and what panpsychism does is liberates
our imagination because it says that
consciousness doesn't have to be located
only in brains whereas the normal view
the neuroscience view is that
consciousness is generated by brains and
therefore it's only in beings with
brains like us the bigger the brain the
more the consciousness
um
whereas pan psychism which considers
whether even electrons and atoms could
be conscious opens the possibility of
saying well is the sun conscious are the
stars conscious i think they probably
are and they meet many of the criteria
for consciousness that one could think
of they have agency they seem to be
self-organizing they they have complex
electromagnetic patterns which could be
the interface between their mind and
and their thoughts
so anyway in what i want to do is
explore this possibility uh in the
context of pan psychism
and you're uh
i've not only have you read my paper on
the conscious sun but i've read your
paper on the philosopher spinoza
his pantheistic views
and
slightly curiously and uniquely
in relation to psychedelic experience
with 5-methoxy
dimethyltryptamine so perhaps i could
ask you to say a little bit about that
yes well i don't know who's the uh who's
the weirdo here um so
[Laughter]
when you put it that way um
so i um yeah so i've done my uh
uh phd on on pan psychism then with
galen strawson who was just speaking as
the examiner
um and um but i always did it below the
human level human level and below uh
going up to the stars
is uh known as cosmopsychism as a sort
of polite term for pantheism really it's
analytic philosophy at least
okay first of all what is five year meow
dmt
5mu dmt is one of the most potent
psychedelics known to mankind
um it uh
i am for research reasons i had to take
some and um
and the reason the reason was that uh
spinozism spinozism is let me explain
spinozism for before five meow dmt
spinozism then was the original
pantheism pantheism was coined by joseph
rafson british mathematician after
spinoza's theory
pantheism means that all is all is god
nature is god and
so spinoza's thought in a nutshell
is um contra descartes who split the
world into mind and matter extension and
thought um spinoza said extension and
thought of minor matter uh matter of
mind respectively were actually
attributes of one substance which he
calls god or nature in other words what
he does is he makes
he argues that as god is the perfect
being
god also has extension god also has
space so god is all of mine but also all
all of space and he argues that in a
very rational
he calls it a geometric method
and um
this
this substance this nature this god has
what he calls an infinite intellect
in other words some kind of
over mind huge cosmic mind
it's um he his his views were suppressed
he was excommunicated by the jewish
community he was his books were banned
by the christian community
for many reasons people said he was an
atheist if you're saying that god is
nature then you're basically saying that
god doesn't exist
um and he said in his book you know god
does not love you so it wasn't the most
christian charitable god
but anyway it interested me
um
i think there's a parsimony to
the philosophy now in relation to
psychedelics in the mystical literature
there's a lot as you know on um
so-called union mystica or unitive
events where you believe
at the least that you are becoming part
of the cosmos this very much sounds like
prima facie at least
spinoza's infinite intellect so i
thought but what is this experience
doing the research i realized then that
5mu dmt was supposed to be the most
unitive of all psychedelics so i thought
perhaps
it would give me an experience
experiential insight into
this theoretic framework that spinoza
had and so and and uh and uh in my essay
i argue that i argue how you can compare
the two phenomenologically with five emo
dmt and uh metaphysically with
spinosadism and that's my general
interest how theories of consciousness
that go beyond the brain
how that has repercussions on
psychedelic experience because um you
know normally we think of psychedelic
experience as hallucinatory they're
called hallucinogens i mean they can be
called hallucinogens
but of course if we expand our
theory of the mind and reality then
perhaps there's some verticality some
truth
to the experience we have
or what say you
well i'm not quite sure where to begin
the psychedelics or spinoza let's start
with spinoza um
i was very interested in your article
because
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas